à noël sous comme il les feux d'artifice
les recoupements les concerts sont
désormais interdits les villes et les
villages de france annuler les
festivités fin d'année alors que nous
sommes tous invités à tester avant de
retrouver les nôtres partout en europe
le même constat
le variant au micro nous menace
réellement riche faune je pense qu'il y
aura une cinquième vague massive notre
niveau de contamination n'a jamais été
aussi élevé en irlande le mot qui fâche
c'est couvre-feu explosion des cas
oblige fermeture obligatoire à 20 heures
pour les bars pubs et restaurants
un nouveau coup dur pour les
professionnels du secteur
à la gare du nord hier soir les
voyageurs se pressaient pour attraper en
eurostar direction le royaume uni juste
avant un durcissement des conditions
d'entrée et de sortie du territoire
je me sens très chanceuse d'avoir réussi
à sortir de france le dernier jour où
c'était possible et belge tom cruise
était encore à londres en plein tournage
du prochain mission impossible mais noël
approche et l'acteur a donc décidé de
marquer le coup il a fait livrer en jet
privé depuis los angeles 300 gâteaux
qu'ils adorent pour toute l'équipe un
aller retour de plus de 8000 kilomètres
à travers l'atlantique vendu 50 dollars
pièce lady gâteau auraient donc coûté 15
mille dollars environ
[Musique]
120 dollars
120 de la niaque à aspen qu'on peut
faire ça ok le mettre dans un don d'un
truc en papier qui trop même et tu
manges tu as tu as créé pas 120 dollars
ah oui c'est ce qu'ont fait les gens les
gens aiment se montrer ça ils sont là en
manquerait fait quand même de l'air un
médecin faut dire que je les fais quoi
c'est rien ils sont environ 5000 à
battre le pavé à londres sur leurs
pancartes
ces manifestants anti vaccins dénonce
des mensonges de la part des autorités
donc juste un moment vous avez parlé des
mensonges donnez moi un objet dont vous
pensez que mensonge et mensonge c'est
quelque chose dont on a connaissance et
dont on dit linverse s'appelle un
lancement avec des masques maintenant
c'était pas un mensonge shrek 2 max
c'est quoi allez vous avez votre belle
il faut creuser pour sortir le cercueil
s'en allait permettre à battice de santé
à l'intérieur le creuse bas propres
troupes c'est beau je trouve que l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
jusqu'au mois de juin de la première
année de gestion sanitaire a dit il
n'est pas nécessaire de porter les
salles je parle de ceux d'aberdeen avait
des stocks de masques alors que vous
n'avez pas non non on n'a jamais dit
qu'on avait des stocks de maïs il ya une
pénurie mondiale et vous avez dit vous
avez des stocks de maintenant
o le casse-tête des villas nous avons
décidé avec le président de la
république qu'un projet de loi sera
soumis au parlement début janvier
notamment pour transformer le pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale et durcir
les conditions de contrôle et de
sanction contre les faux passe désormais
seule la vaccination sera valable dans
le pass le passo tonale est une forme
déguisée de l'obligation vaccinale mais
c'est plus efficace qu'une obligation
vaccinale empêcher les gens d'aller dans
des bars des restaurants dans des lieux
qui reçoit du public s'ils ne sont pas
vaccinés c'est plus efficace que leur
met une amende de 100 euros quand on les
attrape dans la rue on n'hésite plus
parce qu'on ne peut pas remplir les
hôpitaux peut pas continuer à vivre
comme ça sous la menace de vagues
épidémiques
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible
ce nouvel an quoi qu'il arrive il est
déjà impacté par l épidémie parce qu'il
ya des annulations de festivités qui
tombent les unes après les autres la
ville de paris a annoncé hier qu'il n'y
aurait pas de feu d'artifice ni de
concert
pour cela j'envisage d'être candidate à
l'élection présidentielle
de la république française non là
maintenant faut débattre devant les
françaises et les français avec emmanuel
macron avec valérie pécresse eric
zemmour jean-marie le pen veut débattre
ce fut marine le pen qu'est ce que j'ai
dit marine le pen oui bah oups
j'attendais la mue et j'ai pas été déçu
à villepinte
je pensais à venir plus tard en fait
et
à villepinte je les regardais
c'était un discours puis sans empreinte
de gravité
d'un homme d'état
leader du groupe de rock le plus connu
de taïwan
[Applaudissements]
le politicien est à peine reconnaissable
sous le maquillage
et toi
ce soir il y chante devant 20000
personnes
ça très beau souvenir qui date de 1980
quand je chantais la chanson la poupée
et cette poupée vient de loin via deux
des états unis et c'est moi c'est vous
c'est une poupée avec
[Applaudissements]
les musées mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait
au bon dieu qui va être bientôt dans les
sols aussi mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
tous ces messieurs là ils ne sont pas
très bas d'hier sont pas très féministes
ils n'iront pas à voir les tuche qui
cartonne actuellement
alors franck brigitte macron est accusé
d'être un an oui plusieurs publications
affirme nathalie que brigitte macron
trognee à de son nom jeune fille
s'appellerait en réalité
jean-michel trône une rumeur propagée
sur les réseaux sociaux par notamment
des comptes d'extrême droite ou
complotistes qui ont trompeusement
analyser vos ses gestes et puis
détournés par exemple une photo diffusée
dans un documentaire faisant une fausse
comparaison puisque la première dame est
ici à 6 entre ses parents ça fait partie
des références sujets comme ça que vous
pouvez même j'ai lu ça boudet l'un et
l'autre le président et vous le présent
ne boude jamais bien ça m'arrive faites
comme si vous ne répondiez pas et faites
comme si vous ne pouvez pas venir à un
rendez vous non mais là j'ai
l'impression après la remarque second
sentiment amoureux qu'on a parlé d'un
vieux couple donc on va éviter cela
c'est pas ça pour moi un mec c'est un
mec qui va pouvoir derrière toi en fait
genre c'est un mec qui va contre qui tu
aimes bien qu'il te veux mais en fait le
truc c'est que je pense que je suis
quelqu'un de très impressionnant
non mais c'est vrai on
n'a rien ouais mais tu viens d'arriver
mais pas toi pour ta place en fait comme
dirait notre ami stéphane dans la
tradition en a qui fut notre as
[Musique]